he is now entering his fifth year as the
head coach
of your los angeles rams joining us here
on the rich eisen show once again is
sean mcvay how are you coach
i'm doing good rich i appreciate you
having me on man i started to get
sensitive it's been a long time
it has been too long and i'll just say
my bad
i'll just say my bad but i greatly
appreciate you giving me the time and
you know it's in my coming up on two
decades
of of doing something uh like this with
the nfl um
having a head coach on two weeks before
the draft usually i do like having that
cat and mouse game of trying to get
something out of them about their choice
at the first
round but uh my soon-to-be bar mitzvahed
kid
is gonna go to college by the time you
get a first round or the next time
sean you know what that's probably true
you know
not much interest when our first pick is
57 and at this rate you're right we'll
never pick in the first round as long as
i'm coaching here
it's i mean you know hey uh smoke him if
you got him well let's get to the reason
why
uh you don't have first round picks in
the next two drafts
as we're getting set for this year's
draft what what did you see in matthew
stafford that made you think
this is a perfect fit for what i'm
seeing the los angeles rams doing on
offense for a while to come
yeah i think he's a special competitor
rich i've always admired his game from
afar the toughness
the way that he rallied guys around him
you know one of my favorite things about
him is
just watch the way his teammates respond
to him you see some of the quotes that
have come
out uh about him from people that have
been close to him i can't tell you the
amount of people that have reached out
to me whether it's coaches or teammates
that
can't say enough good things about him
and then really when you know it was
made
that he was possibly a guy that could be
on the market you start really studying
his game
uh as if okay we might have the
potential to acquire this guy you're
thinking man he's pretty unique the way
he sees the field
obviously all the you know the ability
in the world in terms of being able to
change the platform to make the throws
and then as you get to know him you
can't help but love the guy
and you see why people speak the way
they do about him and and i am uh
you know fired up to say the least to
get a chance to work with him well one
thing he didn't have in detroit
um is is a consistent running game
uh i mean you you the number of times
apparently
that he had a rusher go for a hundred
yards in a game
and he played there as we know for a
decade uh
is in the teens it's it's not a lot or
it could be 11.
i think i was going to say i think the
number is 11 rich
which uh you know it's tough that
quarterback position is as tough as it
gets
and uh you know i do think you know to
hopefully be able to be a little bit
more balanced
be able to alleviate some of the stress
but but he can certainly do some unique
things in those known passing
situations and um fired up man real
fired up
so um what what exactly if you could
just dive a little bit into the x's and
o's do you think
he can do at the quarterback position
that makes your
system if you will hum in a manner that
maybe we hadn't seen in the last couple
of years
what is that you know i would say this
rich you know
jared has done so many great things for
us so you know i don't necessarily know
if it's you know what hasn't been done i
think it's what matthew brings to the
table
when you do look at what he can do you
know you're able to act
you know execute and activate your play
actions your movements
you know those things but then when you
get into the known passing the third
down
the two-minute drills at the end of the
half end of the game the way that he's
able to move and manipulate the pocket
the way he's able to recognize and
understand coverage and make all five
eligibles come alive
uh the way that he can create off
schedule in the pocket out of the pocket
and just the overall competitiveness and
command
those are the things that i think he
brings to the table you know when you're
really playing that position when you're
asked to
get through progressions recognize read
solve problems protection wise you're
seeing him do a lot of those things
and um you know to be able to you know
work together to collaborate you know
i think you're really excited about that
collaboration because he's got a lot of
good
film and a lot of exposure to different
systems
that ultimately uh you know you'll see
us you know bring into our arsenal
because it starts with the quarterback
always and everything we do
john mcveigh here on the rich eisen show
head coach of the los angeles rams and
i understand me asking about what
stafford
can do in the offense that made you want
to move in that direction
that in this world where we parse every
word that comes out of a
head coach's mouth it might be viewed in
a way as being
denigrating to the guy that was there uh
in jared goff i totally understand that
that said you're um you're attac you're
being attached to the hip of goff being
hired to
do something for somebody who was the
first overall selection in the draft in
this copycat league other coaches
i think were hired based on your success
with jared goff
so i i i'll just give you the macro
question and you can answer it
however detailed as i hope you can what
what happened
with you and jared goff in los
angeles i i would say that you know when
i look at
you know my contribution to it rich i
think
sometimes you can let the uh success get
in the way of the enjoyment and the core
values that you want to operate by
and i i wish i would have consistently
communicated better but you know it's
about
you know producing and certainly that
doesn't fall exclusively on his
shoulders
but the opportunity to acquire a player
of matthew stafford's caliber
is there there's really something to be
said for that that was the intriguing
opportunity that presented itself
but you know when you go back and you
watch there's a lot of good things that
jared did
late and even late in the year i mean
you see the weight played on against
tampa on monday night football and a big
win for us
the way played against arizona uh at a
key part in our season
and then to be able to come in no
practice having the thumb surgery and
lead us to a playoff victory against
seattle so
there's a lot of good things that that
he did i think he'll do a really nice
job in detroit but it it
was a pretty unique opportunity when you
know matthew was made
it was known that he was available and
we kind of explored it and things
accelerated faster than i think anybody
could have anticipated
so but when when do you make that
decision to go
for it i mean being a look obviously you
and les need are known for your
aggressiveness it's not like
we haven't seen something like this
before certainly out of out of less
before your tenure as the hc of the lar
um so at what point you know did you
make this
decision that maybe it wasn't working
out with you and jared goff
in l.a well i think when you look at
just the landscape of the league and the
amount of
conversation that that evolved and
revolved around the quarterbacks that
could be available that maybe one out
that don't
you know he was a guy that's in that
upper echelon of the league and
performed at a high level that was
really the only one that was truly
available you know the lions had said
okay we are going to allow you to seek a
trade
everything else is speculation and so
when that became
kind of publicly known that he had
talked to ownership
and rod wood and they granted that
permission now we're saying all right
let's do our due diligence
really study the player uh fortunately i
do think that some of the relationships
with brad holmes was
helpful in facilitating a lot of that
dialogue where
not getting out but if there is uh you
know a certain level of mutual respect
and trust on
both sides and and really it was as soon
as uh
you know it was made of known that he
was available that we kind of started
exploring it
and the dialogue started and you know
like life's been
kind of reported rich both matthew and i
were in cabo
when everything finalized and you know
as much as
i don't think anybody would believe it
it is true that it happened by
coincidence
so you you weren't like let's go
vacation and uh
and and jump uh into uh the 2021 season
together that uh those threes are
mutually exclusive
is what you're saying yes i i'm saying
you know we're on vacation and then uh
then it's known that hey matthew
stafford and his wife kelly and a couple
of their friends happen to be at the
same resort i said you got to be
me i cannot believe no kidding wow so
you didn't just like go to the spa
together and run into each other in
terry cloth uh bathrobes there literally
was somebody just told you that and you
reached out and then all of a sudden
you're now coaching quarterback
i guess so i mean cabo it was a pretty
uh it was a pretty unique spot
it was uh one of the few that wasn't
restricted right in terms of you know
being opened up
and you know i ran into drew brees was
down there i think sean payton coach
snags
wow uh sean mcvay here uh on the rich
eisen show okay so while i have a few
minutes left with you let's let's have a
little fun because i know you've got
your own house and
to to be concerned about you've got your
own team you've got your own competition
uh in the nfc west uh so commenting
about somebody else's house in your
division is something i'll give a little
bit of a whirl here you know about
evaluating quarterbacks you know about
your system being your system or at
least your scheme being your scheme and
you knowing exactly what's right for
it so and you know about being
aggressive to go get the quarterback
that you want if the opportunity is
there
do you think the 49ers made this trade
to go up to number three overall
without fully knowing which quarterback
not named lawrence or wilson
they're going to take do you think
they're still truly
evaluating who they're taking third
overall sean mcvay what do you think
what what do you think to that uh okay i
like that you're turning the tables
that's a very veteran maneuver
uh i will say i don't think i think they
have to know who they have
they can't say it because anything can
happen
and you know clearly they're not going
to give up the pick they're not doing
this to trade it in for better picks
i think they have to know and i think
they got to go to the owner and saying
this is the guy that we think
um i'm saying nfc yeah with no
chance that there wasn't a strong
feeling or at least an appreciation for
no matter what happens with those first
two picks
right with jacksonville and new york
that we're gonna feel great about it
i do know this and this is what you
always respect about you know kyle
and and when i worked for mike uh
they're gonna do their work
they're gonna be convicted in their
beliefs there's a security that exists
where you know they trust
the expertise and and their you know due
diligence i know kyle's going to be
studying the heck out of these guys that
are possibilities and
um i do think that everything was done
with a with a plan in mind while also
knowing that i'm sure they're still kind
of really ironing out to make sure but
i'd have a tough time believing knowing
how intentional kyle is about everything
and
and john and those guys in san francisco
that they didn't feel good no matter
what the scenario is about either one
or two guys or a few that that would be
available at that third pick when you
when you give that much up to go up but
they might not be sharing it with
many breathing people on the planet but
you think that when they when john lynch
struck that deal with shanahan
with the jed york green light that they
know who they they're gonna take
right now yeah i think i think that
there was an intentionality that no
matter what happened with those first
two picks we're gonna feel great about
giving this
up and what we're gonna acquire in the
player that we choose at the three spot
man what a division arizona keeps adding
people too we all know seattle with the
drama with russell looks like he's
coming back
uh it's a finale you got you you're in a
deep end of the pool man but it's a it's
a fun pool
it's a oh it's not fun
[Laughter]
you know it's a pool that i wouldn't
mind uh you know not being in to be
honest with you but uh
hey it sure makes it fun for you to to
say hey how is it fun swimming in the
deep end six times a year
oh you love the competition plus you've
got the pacific ocean too so you got the
ocean also
uh that's exactly right before i let you
go the subject matter of
off-season workout voluntary off-season
workouts
um being on the table uh
as a conversation piece as well as a
potential
not going to do this piece we saw a
handful of teams already or players
on these teams say they're not going to
participate in any in-person voluntary
off-season
workout programs how do you as an hc in
the nfl
feel about the possibility of voluntary
workouts
not being um once again for a second
straight year
um viable for a lot of players yeah
i think for coaches you know we're
always gonna want the opportunity to
connect
and and work with our players you know
and that's not gonna change
um but i think it is important that
we're listening we're understanding the
perspective that they're coming from
and then figuring out what is the best
way to collaborate
and to be able to communicate with one
another in a way that that ultimately
gets the solution that's best for our
football team and so
i think there's a lot of things that'll
still need to be figured out when you
bring into
you know the conversation vaccines what
does that mean you know the leak came
out with a memo
uh yesterday basically saying hey here's
what the parameters are around
phase one phase two and phase three so
you know we're gonna be all virtual for
the first month with our meetings okay
there'll be an option to come in and
lift and then we'll kind of just take it
a day at a time and we've got to be able
to have the flexibility and the agility
to adjust and adapt accordingly but
it's about listening and really
collaborating with these guys is the
important thing for us and who
is the guy you'd talk to about that is
that a whitworth conversation who else
do you talk to that's an aaron donald
that's a matthew stafford
that is you know jaylen ramsey that's
those guys that have been your leaders
the woods the cups you know
we've got a leadership committee that
that you you know you really lean on
those guys and understand their
perspective and
um you know they're so well thought out
and they've got experience and an
understanding from both ends of the
spectrum and so i think it would be
naive of me not to listen to those guys
coach appreciate it really always enjoy
our chats uh i'll be at the draft on
thursday night um
i'll be thinking of you you know raising
it could be like a trading places across
the country i'll just raise my glass to
you and like
looking good sean feeling good rich or
something like that we could have one of
those type moments
through the television set uh on that
first night of the draft and then we'll
just straight
up the rams the rams coaching staff will
figure out a way to play draft bingo or
something and just watch like fans
i look forward to being the the you
gotta you know you gotta have us on the
on the screen i mean just
no doubt there is an eye in rich and
eisen coach just let's put all pull
together in the right spot okay
let's do that hey i love it i it's
always good to be back on and thanks
sean you know
hopefully sooner than later i can come
see you guys in person too
i look forward to that i pound the table
for that thank you for the call that's
sean mcvay
of the los angeles rams right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here